hello everyone i'm dana perino along
with Dakin McDowell 1 William Jesse
Watters and Greg Gutfeld it's 5 o'clock
in New York City and this is the fact
major revelations from Attorney General
William Barr about the investigation
into how the Russia probe started in his
first interview since the Muller report
was released Barr saying he's not
satisfied with the early answers he's
getting on allegations of Trump campaign
spine I've been trying to get answers to
questions and I found that a lot of the
answers of Benedict inadequate and I
have also found that some of the
explanations I've gotten don't hang
together so in a sense I have more
questions today than I did when I first
started so I think people have to find
out what the government was doing during
that period if we're if we're worried
about foreign influence for the very
same reason we should be worried about
whether government officials abused
their power and put their thumb on the
scale and and so I'm not saying that
happened but I'm saying that we have to
look at that far also commenting on the
steel dossier it's a very unusual
situation to have opposition research
like that especially one that on its
face had a number of clear mistakes and
and some of Zhijun analysis and - and to
use that to get to conduct
counterintelligence against the American
political campaign as a strange would be
a strange development I'm not sure how
what role it played but that's something
we have to look at so Greg I have a
theory no you don't want me to go to you
first okay so my theory is that if you
were in the Obama administration at the
time of the 2016 election and you were
aware of Russian interference and you
were Samara
it would seem to me that you would
welcome an investigation into the
investigation absolutely think of that
theory absolutely but you may have heard
a phrase that I coined recently what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander
no for my uncle Steve what's good for
the goose is good for my uncle Steve he
lives not well I feed him lettuce in
insects oh he's like a goose the dams in
the media has spent two years doing this
you think that they're just gonna let it
go now they're gonna cut that now this
is revenge time this is like evening
this evening the score and you can use
the same argument you could say like we
we know that the Russians tried to
collude we know
the Russians tried to medal now we need
to know how it was done and who helped
them it's the same argument in Reverse
and their dossier the great dossier it's
like a bad batch of egg salad serve to
Everett served at the buffet and
everyone who took a taste got food
poisoning it's the food poisoning of the
news if that's why CNN is so blue in the
face all the time because they they took
the you know the biggest helping that's
why if someone gave you food poisoning
you'd be mad at them right CNN's not mad
and see your point
if you were lied to by the Obama
intelligence officials about collusion
for two years and they humiliated you
you got a nice ratings bump but then at
the end they humiliated you the ratings
are taking a nosedive wouldn't you want
to know why and how you were lied to
it seems like they have no interest in
finding out what went wrong with the
collusion hoax but they don't care now
to your point about the Steele dossier
and the FISA warrant we're learning a
lot more and more about that so the
whole FISA warrant on Carter page looks
like it was based off the steel dossier
major red flag and the steel dossier it
said that they were running this
operation through Carter page out of the
Russian embassy in Miami
there's no Russian embassy in Miami
anyone that could look at that would
know immediately that's a red flag in
Tampa not even in Miami so they also
said the other two reasons they cited
for the warrant was two meetings that
Carter page had with these Russian
oligarchs to hatch this plot both
meetings never happened and then they
used a yahoo news article then you have
Papadopoulos we're now learning that
this is not really what started off the
entire investigation and that's going to
come out he never even spoke to a
Russian and we have now text messages
between Strock and page struck and page
called Massoud the guy that started this
whole thing there guy now if he's a
Russian agent how is he there guy very
very suspicious one two uh if I can
continue as my theory so if you're
Hillary Clinton and you really believe
that this weapon was stolen from you
because the Russians interfered wouldn't
you also want it to be revealed like how
the if you believe that that's true and
you believe that the Obama
administration did the right thing
wouldn't it be a good thing for her
argument for the
people to be able to see what the
origins of the investigation were right
but that's not what's going on here Dana
what's going on is an investigation of
the investigators as punishment coming
from an administration that is
overwhelmingly political I mean right
now really they're distracting from the
real news with all of this silliness
because the real news is that we're
going to soon see transcripts of what
Michael Flynn and Michael Flynn's lawyer
were saying to Trump's lawyers and we'll
see just how much they were trying to
stop this investigation but the second
thing to say here is listening to Bill
Barr
I mean he has no reason to do anything
but what he says is oh uh you know what
let's not talk about the spine I know I
said that earlier what about what
happened between the time Trump was
elected in the time he takes office
let's go and look at what happened in
terms of FBI and intelligence agencies
talking to Trump at Trump Tower did they
leak something he just changes the game
time and again yeah and that's why I
don't things to look that's why when you
look at the Fox News poll that came out
yesterday the Fox News poll says 45% of
Americans believe that bar is covering
up for Trump and not being transparent
and also they give him a negative rating
for how he handled the Mulla report 44%
say they don't approve of what he's done
with the mollow report only 35 destroyed
them if that makes you feel better but
it has no effect on it and it's the
truth the truth another oh it's
irrelevant
the American people are not being
hoodwinked by a guy who is now Trump's
Lorie this is what Trump wished for all
along he wanted an attorney general who
would be his consigliere Mike Holder was
for a what's happening right now the
Russian story is now into its summer
reruns that's what's happening I saw it
on the first run I don't need to see it
again I know what this Flinn stories
about I know how that all that crap
that's because the economy is going well
the world's going pretty it's peaceful
its prosperous everything's fine
they have to keep doing the Russian
story yes Greg don't look here
yeah we already looked for two years now
we're looking at the White House talking
point is this investigation is done no
obstruction no collusion Jerry Nadler
has said to them facing the Russians
from doing it guys can we please get
taking him but first coming here the
Attorney General about this idea about
the very the documents in contempt
that's part of the usual game you know
political circus that's being played out
it doesn't surprise me the House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi she she believes you lied
under oath what do you think of that
charge well I think it's a it's a
laughable charge and I think it's
largely being made to try to discredit
me partly because they may be concerned
about the outcome of a review of what
happened during the during the election
Dagan they're trying to discredit him
because they're worried people who
worked in the Obama administration in
the FBI and in the CIA and the
intelligence community they're worried
whether it's Brennan or Co me or even
subordinates of both of them they're
worried about what Bill Barr and John
Durham and the Inspector General Michael
Horowitz are going to find it's not
silliness one if there was corruption
it's not silliness if there was an abuse
of power and you know why Hillary
Clinton is being quiet about this
because the DNC and Hillary Clinton's
campaign paid for that dossier what
could could be disinformation by Russia
which was if you read the whole Mullen
report the whole mullah report basically
discredits big big elements that were in
that dossier and I just want to point
this out pointed out all the time Jim
Comey looked at Bret Baier in the spring
of last year and said I can't
definitively say I know that the sealed
dossier was paid for by the DNC in the
Clinton campaign he was running the FBI
they got a warrant on an American
citizen to spy on him and he didn't know
that that is balderdash and hogwash and
mm-hmm
we all know it and by the way I also
read that poll one and here's what
people said a majority 58% think it is
at least somewhat likely the FBI broke
the law when it started investigating
the Trump campaign the Mane's of
Americans who don't trust wit went on
in intelligence and the FBI under the
Obama administration they deserve
answers and there's nothing wrong with a
thorough look at it again it disrupts
dis mah cracy in this country look what
we're doing now is we're trying to
punish the investment look at it said I
read the whole mower he did not look at
the investigators and the predicate of
that investigator Oni Muller pick up a
newspaper it'll tell it will how this
start on the press that lied to us for
three years about get a liar all right
you know I'll save it for yes